daniel jackson archaeologist and
defender of earth let's dive into the
history of one of the most beloved
characters in the stargate franchise
welcome to star trek your sci-fi tv and
movie channel
[Music]
in his early years daniel jackson was
convinced of the fact that the pyramids
were created by aliens and they were in
fact landing pads for alien spaceships
he was naturally laughed out of academia
for this but he was shortly approached
by someone from the us government to
join a program that program being the
stargate project this was in 1994.
daniel helped to decipher the glyphs on
the stargate stating that they weren't
numbers or letters they were in fact
star constellations and that the device
in the us government's possession was
called a stargate capable of near
instantaneous travel between two points
shortly after this a mission was green
lit and a team was formed to go to the
planet known as abidos and it was on
this planet that daniel and the rest of
the team found out that the people of
overdose were in fact enslaved
and worshipping a god known as ra now
ultimately they defeated ra they freed
the people of aberdos and daniel jackson
decided to stay on abdos with a woman
that he'd met known as charade daniel
jackson ultimately stayed on abados for
one year but due to the fact that
apophis came through earth stargate the
sgc kind of figured that raw wasn't dead
and sent a team back to abidos they were
originally going to nuke the planet but
jack o'neill who just came back out of
retirement
had to spill the beans that daniel
jackson was in fact alive and living
with the people on ambidex i regret to
inform you that my report was not
entirely accurate
you didn't detonate the bomb no i did
detonate the bomb sir and it was a board
rod spacecraft so it did kill him and
eliminate the risk to earth however
however
raj's ship was in orbit above the planet
at the time
neither the gate nor anything else on
the planet was destroyed
daniel jackson is alive and living with
the people on avatars now when the newly
formed su-1 team go to aberdos they find
that daniel jackson is there with the
people of abidos who have just been
attacked by a guard shari as long as one
of the kids from the planet abbados was
taken as a prisoner so daniel made it
his mission to go for this target and
try and rescue his wife he joined sg1
now throughout the course of the first
few seasons we saw daniel jackson grow
as a character he evolved from james
spader's interpretation of the character
and michael shanks really came into his
own daniel was often the voice of reason
for the team
and he fought for righteousness and
justice his archaeological experience
was invaluable in helping to identify
and translate many alien artifacts now
it wasn't long before charade and daniel
were reunited however
shahrai had been overtaken by aguaw
known as amunet which was the wife of
apophis amunet pulled a ribbon device on
daniel and was ultimately going to kill
him with it so tilke took the only
action he felt he could and fired his
staff weapon
at amunet killing ammunette as well as
shari
now daniel wasn't happy with this daniel
absolutely hated tilk and daniel even
left the sgc stating that his mission
was over he found his wife it's it's
done but he was then plagued by visions
visions from his wife stating that he
needed to find what was known as the
harshest child
now the hearthst child is a child born
from two groud symbiotes which will
contain all of the knowledge of the gold
but doesn't actually have a good old
symbiote daniel rejoined sg-1 on the
mission to find this child now on a
routine mission they eventually found
the planet known as keb where daniel met
a being known as oma desala who was
responsible for helping people to ascend
it was during this time that he learned
all about ascension and learned that
there are different planes of existence
now only a year later they find a planet
known as kelowna where they have started
to build diplomatic relations
now this planet is building a reactor
made out of the quadro which is
kind of a mix of nakuda and some other
materials but it's found deep inside of
a planet the people of kelowna were
creating a power source out of this
mineral and ultimately
they didn't get the formula quite right
what happened was a radiation leak
happened and daniel ended up getting
radiation poisoning now daniel did
actually die
the radiation poisoning
was too much his body broke down and he
died but he was saved by omadisala where
he was given the option to ascend and
therefore shed his physical body ascend
to a higher plane of existence and live
on in the higher planes now during the
time that daniel was ascended he was
replaced by jonas quinn one of the
colonians daniel did eventually return
in the following season and jonas quinn
left the show and throughout the season
daniel essentially died and ascended on
two occasions most notably the second
time he ascended he didn't really like
following the rules you see the ascended
beings who we now know to be the
ancients have a non-interference policy
and although daniel was a member of sg-1
he wasn't allowed to interfere with what
was happening in the galaxy and what was
happening at the time was anubis was
waging war on the entire galaxy killing
all of the goal and even staging an
attack on earth daniel did however help
them to find the eye of ra which was
ultimately taken by anubis and daniel
jackson then decided he was going to
break the rules he appeared before
anubis and attempted to destroy him he
was pulled back by omar dasala and
ultimately he was stripped from the
ascended plane his memory was wiped and
he was left naked on a planet where he
was then discovered by sg1 a few months
later he did rejoin sg-1 and then
continued to go through the galaxy on
routine missions with sg1 he fought
jafar he fought replicators and
eventually found himself in the aurai
galaxy now he was alongside a new member
of sg-1 known as vala maldoran and their
presence in the uri galaxy alerted this
higher plane
god-like species of our presence who
ultimately then
waged a war on the milky way they
invaded now the aura were ultimately
defeated and the last time we saw daniel
he was about to step through the gate on
a routine mission this was a changed
timeline however because the original
timeline sg1 was aboard one of the earth
vessels which was basically destroyed by
an all-right ship they trapped
themselves in a time dilation field to
try and give themselves more time but it
was tilt who ultimately saved the day on
that one and went back in time to change
the timeline so as far as we know daniel
jackson is still going on routine
missions with sg1 wherever he is now
wherever daniel is i hope he's still
curious i hope he's helping
civilizations and finding new exciting
artifacts to help earth for me daniel
was a fantastic character it was in my
opinion the very heart of the show if a
new show is green lit a cameo from
daniel jackson is needed it's almost
like it has to happen because stargate
without daniel jackson would be very
strange indeed
[Music]
you